Republicans Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell has admitted that Donald Trump
will effectively get to direct his own
impeachment trial in the Senate to catch
you up things are moving in the
direction of an impeachment trial in the
Senate against President Donald Trump
likely to be impeached by the full house
any day now maybe already by the time
you get today's show maybe later this
week the trial in the Senate is likely
to happen in January it's going to be
managed by the Senate Majority Leader
who's a Republican Mitch McConnell and
it will then be presided over by the
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
that's John Roberts also a conservative
justice Mitch McConnell has pledged
quote total coordination with the White
House he said this of course on Fox News
while being interviewed naturally by
propagandist Sean Hannity take a look
we'll listen to the opening arguments by
the house prosecutors they will listen
to the president's lawyers respond and
then we'll have to make a decision about
the way forward and everything I do
during this I'm coordinating with white
House Counsel there will be no
difference between the president's
position and our position as to how to
handle this to the extent that we can we
don't have the kind of ball control on
this that a typical issue for example
comes over for the house if if I don't
like it we don't take it up we have no
choice but to take it up but we'll be
working through this process hopefully
in a fairly short period of time in
total coordination with the White House
counsel's office and the people who are
representing the president in the will
of the Senate there is no difference
between the White House and the Senate
on this issue remember that it was
Republicans attacking the house
proceedings in the impeachment inquiry
for being a kangaroo court they are
admitting that the guy who is in
practice the foreman of the jury that's
sort of what Mitch McConnell is has
already decided on the verdict before
the trial has started they have been
talking about the impeachment process is
rigged it seems they are rigging it in
the Senate the usual projection what
they accuse others of they
themselves are doing this is not normal
quote according to the rules expressed
in the Constitution during an
impeachment trial of the President of
the United States the Senate takes an
oath to act as impartial jurors
mcconnell has already said he won't be
impartial he has prejudged the verdict
he said he will coordinate with the
accused the Senate is supposed to be the
jury imagine if in a criminal trial the
foreman of the jury was coordinating
with the defendant that's what we're
talking about here the framers of the
Constitution set up some safeguards like
for example saying that in an
impeachment trial the Senate must
function as a nonpartisan jury they
never imagined that we'd have a
president this corrupt and a Senate
majority leader this willing to prop up
the president's corruption we often say
when they wrote the Second Amendment
they couldn't imagine fully automatic
rifles when they set up the checks and
balances clearly they couldn't imagine a
president this brazen in ignoring the
rule of law and this corrupt combined
with the Senate that is so willing to
shield and protect that same president
and engage in their election of their
duty does this feel sort of wrong to
anybody else is anybody else concerned
about what's going on but remember if
you are we knew this was going to happen
I'm endlessly surprised by how bold and
brazen and shameless they are about it
but we knew from the start the Senate
will acquit we knew this ahead of time
they are now saying it out loud which is
we don't care about the trial we don't
care about the facts we are going to
acquit and we will let the White House
tell us how to run this thing for
whatever Donald Trump perceived to be
his maximum benefit there are whispers
that Donald Trump has been suggesting
that he wants the trial to drag out as
long as possible and that he believes
that will be the best thing for him so
eventually the trial will end will wake
up and realize we don't really have a
democracy here not in any real sense we
don't have checks and balances that
still have clout because the president
has been able to get away with ignoring
them and then hopefully we will vote in
large enough numbers in 2020 to
overwhelm voter suppression
gerrymandering
foreign influence the propaganda and
removed the sky that's the hope that we
overwhelm all of those structural
disadvantages in November of 2020 I see
that as the only possible path forward
and everyday that is becoming clearer
and clearer particularly now that we've
heard from Mitch McConnell on January
1st we're getting ready to start the new
year on January 1st we will have a
massive election year membership special
if you've been thinking of becoming a
member and supporting this show that is
of course the number one funding source
for the show January 1 is the day to do
it we're gonna have a major membership
special it's gonna be obscene quite
frankly how do you get notified just get
on our newsletter go to david pakman.com
upper right corner of the website it
says sign up for the mailing list get on
that newsletter mailing list and on
january 1 you will receive just it's
obscene I lawyers have told me don't
even mention it because it's so
disgusting what we're gonna be offering
on January 1 follow me on Twitter at D
Pakman let me know what you think about
Mitch McConnell and we'll be back right
after this I used to love starting the
day with those sugary breakfast cereals
and then I realized that they're full of
sugar and they're full of excess carbs
this episode is sponsored by magic spoon
which is a new cereal company that has
figured out a way to recreate those
cereals that we loved as kids with zero
sugar 12 grams of protein and only 3
grams of net carbs in each serving they
have some really great flavors my
favorite is cocoa I think we all know
what childhood era
cereal that reminds me of they've
recreated the taste they've recreated
the textures but you would never guess
that these cereals are keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
and GMO free I just love that cocoa one
go to magic spoon dot-com slash Pakman
to grab a variety pack and try it today
use our promo code Pakman at checkout to
get free shipping and magic spoon is so
confident in their product that they
offer a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason you'll get
a refund
no questions asked go to magic spoon
dot-com slash Pakman and use the code
Pakman PA que ma n to get free shipping